[Music]
host Malone had some fun singing along
to one of his favorite Wayne at the
American Music Awards on Sunday night
and today on the talk sh and I reacted
to the viral video and is ready to
record a song with him I didn't I didn't
I didn't get to say hello to him he was
a little bit further down but since he's
doing these collabs and he's a superfan
are you going to record with him
oh I've written a song for us already
[Applause]
[Applause]
huge fans and you got to hang out with
them over the summer would there be a
collaboration in the work there well
listen there's there's a really cool
friendship starting between us and I
after I met those ladies we got off on
stage very impromptu I kind of like
pulled them up there I was being kind of
a mama bear and he said like no no come
on you got to get up here and we gotta
get this thing and we all had a really
great time yeah
so I was very inspired after that I went
home and I actually wrote a song for the
three of us seriously I did
[Applause]
it's called sisters it's called sisters
and I think we're just all sisters and
what we do and it was just it was a
really great new friendship that we
started and so I went home and wrote
that song and yeah so I'm gonna they
don't know that I don't yet
[Applause]
there you go new music on the way from
Shania notices why not it could be fun
to hear kind of says that would be fun
love Shania do you think I love Shania
love Postma I love Janelle Monae I love
whizzo do you think that's gonna work
why wouldn't it work I don't know like
just like okay with post and Shania you
can see you're working no you can't see
a work out how you would really combine
like what would it sound like I don't
really see how they would find a voice
that would smell and Liz oh I don't do
that it's funny I see both those
pairings I think in media I'm like okay
I can sort of I can see how this might
play out yeah yeah each of those wonder
why yeah it's nice I mean sure with the
one for Liz oh and Jenelle like back in
the summer so like why isn't she
presented that time I'm not I'm more
shocked that she like
after meeting people she goes home and
writes songs yes like who'll write a
song for the two of them to perform yeah
I haven't met Jenna yet but I'm hoping
that when I do she'll write a song for
the two of us sing together I hope maybe
one day the other one was Harry Styles
that people want see that working is it
because of both were a leopard print
like is that why sure yeah yeah but I
just felt like maybe it would work and I
love both of them and I is a great
songwriter but yeah like just on on
paper in theory I don't I'm something
like I'm a little birds in the song